I want to talk to you about Valentine's
Day because I'm a little confused by it
sometimes it can feel like a bit of if
you're a guy can feel like a bit of a
trap women say it's not a big deal
they're lying they're lying yeah we know
that we lie right carry to get me then
you're judged for it yes I feel the
pressure of judgment if I do this wrong
do you know what I mean and so and and I
think a lot of guys feel that yeah well
I think it's important because about
probably like two months ahead of time
women's stop startling dropping hints
they'll take you by the store sort of
close to the thing they like and they'll
sort of point it out whether it's a
jewelry store or a clothing store or a
7-eleven that's how things roll in my
house you want to slim-jim you're
getting a slim jim
yeah but then if you got help god help a
guy if he doesn't get it quite right
it's right then you can you know tell
his best friend or tell your best friend
to just sort of send him an email or
something now you're a singer you are
quite good at crafts doing things
yourself do you get into ever making
Valentines making stuff you seem like
someone who'd be into that yeah I get
super into it and I start researching
like a month ahead of time what I think
the children's Valentines should be
really absolutely like searching the
internet going oh my god well the cutest
thing they have this great website
called Pinterest and it's I like that
website too
he's flying from what I can sort of see
it's mainly for women and it's mainly
just a collection of the most amazing
wonderful craftiness on the earth and it
had beautiful pictures of little puppies
but it'll have great ideas for
Valentine's it gives them stuff like
that but I'm they have great things like
they like you could print out this thing
it says I'm a sucker for you and then
you tape a sucker on it I'm good now
wait a minute so so this is something
you can build yeah no it's not by the
way this company this website is very
happy right now that you mentioned them
you're gonna get some free stuff I'd
like to mention Porsche by the way
so especially hybrid right I like that I
say the planet should take care of
itself do you get I you know I was by my
kids school the other day and I was
looking at the kids projects that are
hanging on the wall and we make a point
of not helping our kids with their
projects and so they go to school and
they really you can tell like no adult
help them we did yeah and it's just
things are misspelled and they just
threw some glue on a piece of paper and
then I see other project and it's so
clear that the parents completely made
this thing which parent are you okay I'm
a little suspicious can you let your
child leave the house with a sloppy
project that you didn't help with um I
have to do everything in my willpower to
contain myself but yes for their greater
good I try to constrain my just
discomfort at the sloppiness or
something just clean up that tea there I
can't really read it very well and what
do you get like it's fine mother leave
me alone that's what I get just leave me
alone and shut up yeah hearing that
voice yeah I'm just gonna back off I'm
stuck at my wife my wife has said this
many times we'll talk and she'll say oh
I have such a girl-crush on this person
or I have such a girl-crush on that
person
she said it about you she's like I have
such a girl-crush I'm Reese Witherspoon
and I'm like oh okay what does that mean
yeah let's get a camera
you know I know your wife I know you do
yes this is perf night on comin I know
fortunately she doesn't watch the show
not a fan
do you have girl crushes I didn't even
know about this idea until my wife
introduces the idea to me oh yeah I have
lots of girl crazy celebrity girl
crushes well I have you know I have a
girl crush on Rachel Bilson because I
think she's so cute and then I also have
a major girl crush on Jennifer Aniston
but I mean I think that's right does
everybody have a crush on generate like
dogs have crushed a lian's and others I
wish it was me and Varley amazed yeah
yes so have you told her have you told
her I have a girl crush I had to give
her an award
about six months ago and I played her
younger sister on Friends mainly so I
could meet Jennifer Aniston yeah she's
just a lovable and amazing and yeah so I
told her publicly in front of a group of
a lot of people which is makes me feel
safer yes gonna come of it yeah that's
why I said my creepy thing in front of
everybody I feel like I'm safer now